off-gem has revealed the price cap that
will apply to around 22 million
households on variable dual fuel tariffs
from april and the new cap is
1971 pounds that's up 54
almost 700 pounds more on the 1277
that applies today this is what the
price cap has looked like since it was
introduced in 2019 worth noting that a
year ago it was just over a thousand
pounds this is what it looks like today
you can see the leap between the current
rate and the new rate that will apply
from april so what explains this record
increase well the main driver is
wholesale energy cost primarily of gas
up 104 per cent as global demand has
grown operating costs are up nine
percent but more interesting are the
network costs up
39
that's explained by energy companies
taking on around 2 million customers
from suppliers that have gone bust in
the last year that cost 2 billion pounds
and recouping it has added 68 pounds to
every bill and finally the policy costs
they include social measures like the
warm homes discount but also green
levees which fund schemes like
insulating customers homes they're
controversial on the conservative back
benches but they've actually fallen 4
at the moment renewables are saving
consumers 20 pounds per bill so green
taxes are not driving up bills but with
households facing a
693 pound rise what's the government
going to do about it first there'll be a
200 pound rebate in fact it's a loan to
every energy bill payer it won't be
available until october after the next
price cap review and it will be repaid
with 40 pounds added to your bills for
the next five years council taxpayers in
bands a to d which the treasury says
covers 80 percent of households will
also get a 150 pound discount that still
leaves four out of five households
facing a
343 pound increase in energy bills huge
by any standards and it's only one
factor in the cost of living squeeze a
1.25
increase in national insurance is coming
in april by which time the bank of
england says inflation will have reached
7.25 percent come the autumn the energy
price cap is forecast to rise again by
another 300 pounds to perhaps 2 300
pounds taken together family's
disposable income is forecast to decline
by 2
if the pandemic is finally in retreat
there'll be no windfall with which to
celebrate